BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: So what
are we going to learn today?
We're going to talk
about the three
products that make up APM--
Stackdriver Trace,
Stackdriver Debugger,
Stackdriver Profiler--
with a high-level demo,
perhaps an announcement.
And then Nejc's going
to come up to talk
about how he uses
this at Outfit7
to make meaningful changes.
So before we get
started, I just want
to learn a little bit
about the audience.
So how many of you guys
consider yourselves developers,
have a developer title?
And how many more on
the operator side?
How many are both?
And how many of those
hold the title SRE,
or something similar to that?
Awesome.
Good bunch.
Now as far as
Stackdriver goes, who's
familiar with Stackdriver?
And who uses Stackdriver
in production today?
Awesome, great.
So we've got a lot of usage, so
we'll make this really quick.
But for those who didn't
have their hand up,
Stackdriver is Google
Cloud's observability suite.
So we try to make Google the
most observable cloud as much
as possible and help you
learn more about what's
happening your environment,
so you can resolve problems
quicker and make meaningful
performance changes,
reduce cost, and
just, overall, help
to run the best system
you can with the best
possible information.
And our job is really to help
you guys help your customers
to make that a reality.
So the Stackdriver portfolio
consists of four main tools,
or main groups of tools.
There's monitoring,
logging, APM, and IRM.
IRM is our newest--
Incident Response Management.
We're talking about
APM today, which
is Application
Performance Monitoring,
and it's meant to be used in
context of everything else.
APM gives you part of the
story, that deeper level
of debug information.
However, we do want to make
sure that you also have that
paired with metrics for good,
statistically relevant data
and logs for that more
traditional, troubleshooting
style information.
So from a high-level
perspective,
let's talk about APM.
As I mentioned, there are
three products in the suite--
Trace, Profiler, and Debugger.
Trace is our distributed
tracing product.
Now, who here has heard
of distributed tracing?
Who's familiar?
Probably the same people who put
up their hands for Stackdriver.
And how many people
are using distributed
tracing in production today?
Awesome.
And keep your hand up if you're
using Stackdriver's Trace?
OK, cool.
So for those who didn't
have their hand up,
distributed tracing helps you
to visualize the request as it
flows through your environment.
This is especially important
in microservice-based
applications.
And the goal is to help
you determine the root
cause faster, analyze trends,
and understand your topology
and how your services
call each other
and, ultimately, to
make meaningful changes,
as I mentioned before.
So to illustrate this,
here's an example
of what an application
architecture could look like.
You have your users connecting
to your load balancer, which
sends traffic to the front end,
multiple back end services,
perhaps compartmentalized.
Not monolithic applications,
as things once were.
And that communicates
to multiple back
end platform services,
such as databases,
analytics layers, data
warehouses, et cetera.
However, today things
look a little bit more
like this, where things
are more chaotic,
and we're talking
about hundreds,
if not thousands, of
small microservices
is working together
for a common goal.
And this is where tracing comes
in, shining a light on the path
that your requests take
through the system,
so that you can
troubleshoot problems
a heck of a lot easier.
If you can only see
one very small part
of an overall picture,
it's quite difficult
to understand the root
cause of a problem.
Context matters, flow
matters, and tracing
helps you understand
that full path.
So without further
ado, we're going
to do a brief demo
of Stackdriver Trace,
and we'll start here
on the Overview tab.
So here in the
Overview tab, you can
understand your most common
requests-- your URIs, your RPC
calls, and their
associate latency,
plus a snapshot of your
last analysis report.
But most the magic is actually
in the Trace Waterfall view.
Now, for those of you
familiar with Stackdriver,
you'll see that this UI
looks a little bit different.
This is actually something
that we've recently
launched to Alpha.
If you're interested,
reach out to me,
bryanzimmerman@google.com.
Bryan with a y.
We'd love to have you join.
It looks a little bit
different in the past,
but the goal is still the same,
that you can use these filter
terms to really find
the trace that you're
trying to find that helps you
identify the problem you're
trying to troubleshoot.
Now, once you find a trace, you
simply select it from the list,
and you can see it pop up
in the Waterfall View below.
So each of these bars
are basically a span--
sorry, they're what
we call a span,
and a span is effectively
a call to a service.
So the route span encompasses
the entire request,
and every child span
is a downstream service
that that request calls, so
you can understand that flow.
Here, we've got an overall
request that's quite long.
There's lots of calls.
And a lot of them, if you
look, are very similar.
It's calling get product, which
is calling get product again.
There's a lot of
repetition here.
We're not quite sure why.
Off to the right-hand side,
it's even more apparent
that you have an
overall trace time
of 31,000 milliseconds,
which is obviously not
acceptable by any user.
But 29,000 milliseconds
of that total
is actually caused by these
14 calls to the get product,
so this is obviously
the cause of the problem
and what we need
to troubleshoot.
And you can understand
how this might
be difficult to surmise
without a product like Trace.
Each one of these calls
isn't by itself wrong
and isn't by itself
horribly long.
But when you put them
together, their overall impact
to the whole is substantial
and really the root cause
of what is a significant
user-facing issue.
Once you identify which is the
service you're interested in,
you can click on it to get
more contextual information,
correlate with log data,
look at event data.
And you can actually send
a custom timed or not
timed annotations that
show up in the service.
Now, while we're on the
subject, from an instrumentation
perspective, we actually
recommend you adopt OpenCensus.
My colleague, Morgan,
has a talk on Thursday
to talk about that exhaustively.
So we won't have time
to go into it today,
but that's a talk that I
would definitely attend.
Lots of great information.
The analysis reports
gives you more
of an understanding of things
from a trend perspective.
So in addition to understanding
that particular trace,
that one little
request, if I want
to understand what's happening
overall with my service, what
has changed in a major or minor
way that might be affecting
my users' experience, even
if it's not immediately
apparent to me,
the analysis report
does the math to bring
it to the surface.
And those can either be done
on-demand or automatically.
In this particular
example report,
we can see that the
high end 95th percentile
latency is great,
but for some reason,
my 50th percentile
latency, which
is the general case
for performance,
or the general case for
my users' experience
is double what it used to be,
so that's obviously a problem,
And you can see that in the
percentile groupings below.
And you can actually even
drill into example traces
to understand what
exactly is happening
in that instance
for that report.
And that gives you a
high-level view of Trace,
and we're going to move to
the next product in our suite.
So how these fit together
is they are designed
to work as a team, of course.
Trace helps you get
from problem to service.
Profiler, which Morgan
will talk about,
helps you get from
service to method.
And Debugger, which
is the third product,
helps you get from method
to the actual problem
that you're seeing.
And it does this by
allowing you to take
a debug information on the fly.
So without a tool like
this, if I have a problem,
I might look at the logs, try
to understand what's happening,
stare at the code a bit,
come up with a theory.
And maybe I have the log lines
that I need, but more likely,
I have to add a debug module
for some additional logging.
Then I have to deploy that,
perhaps restart the service.
Then I'm going to
wait for the problem
to happen again,
search the logs,
and repeat on and on, until
I understand the problem.
Well, with Debugger,
because you can
take snapshots to
inspect local variables
and add log lines in production
safely without restarting,
without redeploying,
you can tighten
that troubleshooting
flow quite a bit.
Your lengthy deploys
are out of the equation,
and that makes it quicker
for you to get to resolution,
affecting customer impact.
And let's see what this
looks like in real life.
So we're going to open
that same application,
and we're going to go
to an example log line.
Taking a snapshot is as
simple as clicking on the line
I'm interested in.
See on the right-hand side
it's waiting for that snapshot
to be hit.
The next time that piece
of code is executed,
it will gather all
the information
about the local
variables at that time,
to the limit of what's
reasonable from a performance
impact perspective.
Most of the magic of this is
actually in making sure that it
does not impact production,
making sure that
your conditions-- which
you can add, by the way,
you can have this snapshot
only taken when you need--
or the expressions to print
certain variables, et cetera,
aren't going to impact
your running code.
And then it's run in
a sandbox to make sure
that it's not actually going
to impact from a resource
perspective or affect the
bytecode, as I mentioned.
The actual snapshot is over
here on the right-hand side,
and we can walk the
call stack, look
through the local variables at
any that have been captured.
If the one you want
isn't captured,
you can add that to the
expression, no problem.
And that really gives you
that deep-level information
of, OK, well, what's happening
in production right now?
So if you've ever
troubleshot an issue
that you could not reproduce
in QA, Debugger's for you.
If you've ever forgotten to
add a line of log statement
that you wish you had,
Debugger's for you.
So these are the kind of
problems we try to solve
And with that being
said, I'm going
to hand things over to
my colleague, Morgan,
to talk about Profiler.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Thanks, Bryan.
So if you attended
Cloud Next last year,
you probably would've seen
that we announced Stackdriver
Profiler;s public beta on
stage at the keynote and during
the APM breakout.
Since then, we've had a
ton of customer success
stories of Profiler.
I'll get into those in a minute.
But we're really,
really proud of how far
the product has come.
For those who aren't
already aware,
Stackdriver Profiler
is a production code
performance analysis tool.
It runs continually on your
production applications,
with effectively no
performance impact,
and allows you to dive
into code all the way down
to the function level to see
where your code is being slow
and where it's
costing you resources.
Profiler, today, works
on applications that
use Java, Node, Go, and Python.
We recently added
Python support.
And as of today, Profiler
is now generally available,
which is what we're
really excited about.
Now talk is cheap, and
it's difficult to describe
some of these products
from a high level,
so I'm going to dive
into a demo to show you
how we can use Profiler
to debug performance
problems on a running
production application.
Perfect.
So this is one of the instances
of the Hipster Shop demo
that you've probably seen
in many, many Google talks.
It's a microservices
application--
I think it's the same one that
Bryan was using in his demo--
with a whole bunch of
services inside of it,
written in different languages.
Right now, we're using Profiler
to inspect the product catalog
service.
The service, I think,
is written in Go,
and it's the
database of products
inside this fake
e-commerce application.
So to start, Profiler aggregates
your performance data down
by the service.
This product catalog
service, I think,
has about five instances.
We're viewing the
performance information
across all of those.
As I mentioned, this is
running in production
with effectively no
performance impact, which
is what separates Stackdriver
Profiler from most
other profiling tools.
It runs continually.
You don't turn it on
for a brief period
and then turn it off again.
You don't have to turn
it on and freak out
that it's going to take
down your system by adding
extra load.
It's very efficient.
It's very intuitive.
Profiler can inspect the
performance of your code
across CPU performance,
memory performance,
and thread contention.
Today, we're going
to look at CPU.
You can, of course,
break down your profiles
across zones or different
versions of your app.
We're not going to do that
today, but it's available,
and there's some other filters
I'll gets to in a minute.
By default this is what you see.
This is a flame graph.
If you've used other
profiling tools,
you're probably
familiar with this.
On the flame graph, on
the horizontal axis,
we're showing the performance
cost of every function.
Each box that you see
on the flame graph
represents a function
in your code base.
And so, functions that are
taking more horizontal space--
so like the one I mousing over--
take up more,
basically costing you
more in terms of
performance and money.
On the vertical axis, we're
showing you the call tree.
So in this case, we've got
streams that 1.1, that calls
handles stream, the calls
process [? UnerRPC, ?]
and so on.
And so right away, we
can tell that we're
burning about half our CPU on
this big stack on the left,
and if we dive into
it, we'll discover
that this is related to JSON
serialization, deserialization.
Probably not something you want
to be spending a lot of time
on a catalog service that's
effectively a database.
We'll come back to the
in-depth performance
of that in a minute.
So flame graphs are
great for finding out
problems where you have like one
big function in your code base
or one big stack that's
consuming a lot of resources.
And yeah, we've had a
lot of customers who've
had gotchas like these, but
Profiler's a lot more powerful
than just finding that.
What I'm going to open next is
what we call the Focus Table.
The Focus Table shows us where
we're burning CPUs, aggregated
across all functions.
You can sort this
by self-consumption.
Self-consumption of a
function is the amount of CPU
or memory burned
by that function,
but not by its children.
Or you can sort it by
the total consumption.
In this case, we're
going to zoom in here
on the state and
string call, which
is burning over 5% of our CPU.
This brings us to
the Focus View.
So Profiler isn't just useful
for finding the performance
impact of your code.
It's also useful for finding how
your code actually calls itself
in production.
This Focus View has taken every
instance of state and string
in our application, and it's
showing us the different ways
that we can get there from root
and how the performance cost
of each of those call paths.
This particular case--
it's not telling us
anything really interesting.
What is interesting
about Focus is
that it will also show you all
the ways out of that function.
And we can observe
that there are none,
so there's no other functions
listed under state and string.
That tells us that
if we're tasked
with improving the
performance of the service,
state and string is a
good place to start,
because it's
burning its own CPU.
It's burning over 5%
of the CPU aggregated
across the entire system.
And finally, it's not it's not
spending that time in its child
functions.
If you want optimize it, you
can optimize that function
on its own.
One of the other
features of Profiler
that we've had since
the start is coloring.
A lot of our customers have told
us how aesthetically pleasing
Profiler is, but then when we
ran a survey of our customer
base and asked them what they
thought the colors represented,
they all told us
they had no idea.
This gave us some data that we
should probably change things.
So starting one
or two weeks ago,
we added different
coloring modes to Profiler.
I'll show you those now.
Probably the most useful is the
total cost coloring mode, which
generally colors the graph--
excuse me-- recolors
the graph, so you
can see where you're
burning CPU more visually.
This is a bit of
an obvious example.
These functions were
already taking up half
of the horizontal
space, but there
are a lot of
situations where you
can use this, like the
Focus Table, to find
and code that's burning
CPU, and it's sprinkled
throughout your code base.
Finally, one of the
really interesting
features we have is
called weighted filtering.
So this example is an
app that, in its best
case or its average case,
has this JSON deserialization
function that's consuming
about half its CPU.
That's already egregious,
just to be clear.
But you can get many workloads
where the usage or consumption
is somewhat bursty where,
during normal periods,
you know, nothing looks like
it's out of whack or that it's
weird.
But you'll have periods where
your system's under higher
stress, there's some kind of
background process running
or something else where,
suddenly, the characterization
of the CPU performance is
dramatically different.
Because Profiler's an
aggregate analysis tool,
it generally wouldn't be good
at capturing those, which is why
we added weighted filtering.
So what weighted
filtering lets me do
is analyze the profiles from
periods of peak consumption.
What I'm going to
do here is jump
to the CPU profiles
captured when the CPU was
at its top 5% of utilization.
Right here, we can see that that
parse catalog function, that's
burning our CPU and all of
the deep JSON deserialization
functions underneath
it, are now consuming
over 90% of our system's
consumption, as opposed
to the average case
that was close to 50%.
And in fact, we can even
do a nice comparison here,
where we can compare the weight
of the top 5% to the average.
And right away, we can see
that this new coloring mode
that, yes, that's, in fact,
exactly where the increase
in CPU consumption has gone.
So Profiler is
great for improving
the performance of
your application,
like we've done here.
It's also a very powerful
cost-reduction tool.
Some of our largest
Google Cloud customers
have reduced their aggregate,
like their fleet-wide CPU
spend, by over
10% with Profiler,
and there's some who have
achieved even bigger gains
in the 20% to 30% range.
It's incredibly powerful.
It's something we use
inside of Google across most
of our services all the time,
to both save money and optimize
the performance of our code.
As I mentioned before,
Profiler has been available
as a beta for the
last year or so.
It is now generally available,
is fully supported by Google,
and we're just really,
really happy to see where
we're going to take this next.
To that end, I'm going to
invite Njec from Outfit7
to come on stage and show us
how Outfit7 has used Profiler
to reduce their costs
and dramatically improve
the performance of
their applications.
Thank you.
NEJC SEVER: Thanks, Morgan.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Nejc, and I'm a
senior software engineer,
working in back end development
team for Outfit7 mobile games.
And today, let's
all imagine that we
want to improve our
code performance
and make our
operational costs lower.
And I'm going to
share with you how
we do this at Outfit7
using App Engine Standard,
and how Profiler makes that
process easier for you.
But first, let me get to know
you with Outfit7 and my friend
here, who will be joining me
throughout this presentation,
Talking Tom.
So for Outfit7, it all
started back in 2010,
with a game called
"Talking Tom."
And at that time,
"Talking Tom" turned out
to be a worldwide phenomenon.
And from that funny
mobile game, Outfit7
grew to be one of the
fastest-growing family
entertainment companies
on the planet,
and is now the fourth
biggest publisher
of mobile games by downloads.
So at Outfit7, it's all
about good and honest fun,
and that's also the main reason
why "Talking Tom and Friends"
franchise is known
and loved by fans
of all ages and generations.
Now, did you know
that on average,
every single one of you has
downloaded one of our apps
before?
And that's because we have
more than 9 billion downloads.
And you can go to any
favorite mobile app store
and download one of our 21
free-to-play mobile games,
ranging from top
Tamagotchi games, runner
games, or other
genres, and we also
have some multi-player games.
We have around 350 million
monthly active users.
Jus to put that
number in perspective,
it's like every US
citizen would play
our apps on a regular basis.
But as you might
know, great looking
games are not enough to deliver
all this fun through such
a huge fan base
like Outfit7 has.
Behind the scenes, we
ran complex systems,
like real-time game servers
and analytic pipelines
that need to scale massively.
But today, I would
like to be focusing
on the backbone between client
devices and our back end
servers.
So our main mobile back end
runs on App Engine Standard.
And we are on App Engine
Standard since the beginning
because it enables you to focus
mainly on application code,
while the infrastructure is
automatically managed for you.
We run more than 10
App Engine services.
For our main database, we
are using Cloud Datastore,
and for orchestration tasks,
we are using Cloud Tasks.
So let's see how we
profiled this app before.
First, we needed to set up
a local development server.
This was quite an easy
step because it comes out
of App Engine SDK by default,
so that was quite an easy step.
Then, we needed to define
different profiling scenarios.
And by this, I mean different
application entry points
where your code needs
to perform well.
And this step is
really important
because different entry
points to your application
can lead to totally
different execution paths,
and those different
execution paths
target different
aspects of your code.
And here, we also have to
consider both requests coming
from client devices and
those from backgrounds
running processes.
Then, we needed to populate
some production-like data
to our local database.
We did this through some helper
scripts for data population.
But as you might
know, as time goes on
and application code changes,
so do data store entities,
and you have to manage
both application
codes and those scripts
that populate the data.
Otherwise, you can
do profiling easy.
So we had our
production-like environments
set up on our local
development server.
Now, we need to generate
some traffic to it, in order
to get some sampling data
for the profiling stage.
Luckily for us, we have a
great integration testing team
that has most of our
use cases covered
and can generate quite
a good load for us
to be able to profile
our application.
So the last step was
to attach the Profiler,
some third-party profiler, to
the running local development
server and analyze the results.
So as you can see, this
process was really tedious,
and there was little
to no automation to it.
And at the end, we could
still make some use cases
because it was just an imitation
of the production environment,
and it wasn't actually
running on production.
So Stackdriver Profiler made
that process simpler for us.
It gets rid of all of
the necessary steps
that we needed to take before,
and all we are left to do
is to attach Stackdriver
Profiler to our App Engine
application.
And that is as easy as inserting
one line into App Engine
configuration and
applying it to production.
So our local development server
gets replaced with a production
server.
All the data and traffic
is running on production,
so there is no limitation of
the production environment.
And as you can see,
this process is so easy
that it also makes
our Talking Tom,
our friend here, a
little bit happier.
So using Stackdriver
Profiler we are already
able to get rid of some of
our other memory exceptions.
Those, quite often, cause some
of our batch processing jobs
to fail.
And using the
Profiler's dashboard,
we were able to spot the
high-memory consuming functions
and split them
into multiple parts
and got rid of the problem.
We also did some
performance checks,
and we reduced the CPU usage on
some of our App Engine services
to around 15%, which also made
our operational costs lower.
But one interesting case that
I would like to point out
today was of some
bad afternoon deploy.
So here's the story.
We had some late
afternoon deploy
with the code that
patched old code
reviews, unit test, integration
test, and staging environment.
And at the end, it still
triggered our alerting system,
and an alert was indicated
that we had an increased
number of instances running
on some of our App Engine
services.
So we went quickly through
code change history,
but we were unable
to spot any suspects
because the change
in the code was
so subtle that at first glimpse
it didn't affect performance
at all.
So using-- before the
Stackdriver Profiler,
we would either revert
the full deploy, which
would postpone our
deployed features,
or we would postpone the
investigation of the problem
until the next day, which
means our costs would increase,
because we would run multiple
App Engine instances.
But with Stackdriver
Profiler, using
the feature when you can compare
two versions to each other,
we compared--
we split 50% of the
production graph traffic
to the latest version and to
the one before the broken one.
And Stackdriver
Profiler dashboards
has this neat feature when
you're in comparison mode--
it highlight the functions that
are performing better or worse
with three different colors.
And using this feature, we
were able to quickly pinpoint
the problem and got rid of it
in a matter of half an hour.
So what's the greatest
Profiler value for us?
The fact that it's
so easy to deploy
and that it runs on
production environment--
this opened quite a few
opportunities for us.
We are now able to
do code performance
checks on a regular basis, which
means our code runs smoother,
requires less resources to run,
and it also affects our cost
in a positive way.
We also have great
insights to our application
because, before,
App Engine Standard
was really a black box for us.
And the last point that
I would like to make
is Stackdriver Profiler is also
now a tool to react to alerts.
So for example, if
we to get an alert
for increased
number of instances
running on App
Engine, this means
that our costs will be higher.
If we get an alert
for increased latency,
this means bad user experience.
And now, if we get
these alerts, we
have new tool to check if
the cause of those alerts
is in bad performing
code, which we
weren't able to do that before,
at least not that quickly.
So I hope that in this
short presentation,
by me showing you how Outfit7
manages code performance,
you gained some
knowledge, and you
can apply it next time that
your code performance suffers.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
MORGAN MCLEAN: Thanks, Nejc.
So what we've shown you today is
Google's Stackdriver APM suite,
and we've shown you where that
exists inside of Stackdriver
and where Stackdriver exists
inside of Google Cloud.
First, you were shown
Stackdriver Trace,
which is a distributed
tracing solution that
allows you to understand how
requests and chains of requests
propagate through your services,
and help you better understand
your services topology.
Then you saw
Stackdriver Debugger,
which effectively lets
you set breakpoints safely
in your production apps.
Finally, we showed you
Stackdriver Profiler--
just going GA today.
Gave you great
customer story for it.
Before we go to
questions, I do want
to interject with two things.
Firstly, all of
these products will
run on applications
running basically anywhere.
That includes App Engine
Standard, Compute Engine,
Kubernetes Engine.
It also includes
applications running
on premises or on other clouds.
Our platform support
for Stackdriver APM
is extremely strong.
Secondly, we've very
good language support.
Pricing?
Stackdriver Profiler
is currently free.
Debugger is currently free.
Stackdriver Trace has pay for
usage that's very generous,
and there's also a
very large free tier.
[MUSIC PLAYING]